Oh Oh what I can unveil our cameras are
out he can unveil the long long damn and
fabulous the Harahan all right here's is
I we have a lot of pictures in the
studio people painted and there's
nothing like a messy look like but
actually yet looks like all that's gonna
get a good spot but he's been working on
this for like three years he started
this all of a sudden I go and finish up
my portrait finish and then all of a
sudden we finally get it wow that's
great
look at the detailing like your clip me
there tonight way that you know there's
there's my body that I just a gif right
yeah
all of the things little bit yeah I've
been waiting to watch oh yeah I know my
mother was getting sick of looking at it
looks really good oh wow
nice little gift here a couple of years
late but Todd Marinovich I I told you
before we went to a commercial break
that he's really a great artist and he's
contributed a couple things to the man
cave also played a little football for
USC and the Raiders and the CFL to learn
more about Todd Todd Marinovich calm to
see all of his artwork there but you
started this a while ago I did I finally
got around to completing it what have
you been doing in the meantime here you
know when I started the the painting as
you know on the set I took it home and
once I got the likeness of you to my
liking I thought eh I did it I was happy
with it a lot of time when I'm painting
I'm not trying to come up with anything
and I was working on your sport coat and
it had this Matador look to it and so
what I've learned is don't
excited just go with it and then as I'm
finishing it finishing it up I I think
of sports in America like this Raging
Bull and that will trample you and not
even think anything of it and most
people don't have the balls to get in
the arena with it and I've watched you
Dan over the decades do it with such
grace and and almost like a dance
reminiscent of the matador wow that's
deep no I'm very shallow well done thank
you
all right let's dive into this yes
please because was it a year ago that we
had taught on maybe year and a half here
okay I'm studio all right then all of a
sudden read about you relapse and yes
now what don't we know about that
situation well here's the deal I've had
physical sobriety before and what I have
today is completely different and I was
never willing to do the work it takes to
to treat my illness and now that I've
treated it the actual the problem has
been removed and now it's up it's my
responsibility to keep it removed and a
big part of that is a service work and
but how does this incident happen what
led up to this drug is an alcohol ban
yeah without a doubt but there has to be
a moment where you go if I go here I'm
not coming back like I can't just do a
little right right yeah like you yeah
went all in yes I can't you know what my
body doesn't know the difference between
street drugs or prescription drugs
it's just when I put drugs into my body
or alcohols it tells me as I want more
and and then all bets are off
so you know what I've been in recovery
before but not it's different today in
the sense like I said I've why all of a
sudden the willingness to do the work
well in humiliation at a whole new level
self-loathing and
really wanting a different life and
willing to do that and you know what a
lot of people don't want to do the work
and that and that's why people want to
tell people what they want to hear right
right and you guys are good liars yes
master manipulators let me tell you yes
and your but you have to tell a wife or
you have to tell kids I mean you're
lying to a lot of different people
without a doubt and that's the number
one thing probably the biggest
liberating feeling I've experienced as a
human being is being honest completely
honest and now I get to you know what if
you would have told me that I'm getting
in front of 2,000 people sharing my
story and being completely open and
honest I would said you're absolutely
crazy you're on drugs yeah but it's the
most gratifying experience that I've
really had and I do that I was in
Florida doing it I'm in Torrey Pines
high school at the end of the month and
it's it's issues that we need to address
because I was out of high school in
South Orange County where check this one
out 23 students are dead from the class
of 2008 because of opiate opiate like
did a death and that is just staggering
did painkillers I know you tried pot in
high school
alcohol I try I did a little more though
you died yeah okay but when did
painkillers come into this and did they
play any role in you sort of when you
were playing that all of a sudden you're
like you know I love this field I you
know what yes
it's that warm fuzzy feeling that all
painkillers give you that I I enjoy but
it was heroin the same field is that the
rat buzzing yeah no boy you had the same
I mean if you go like if grandma breaks
her hip and she goes the doctor she's
going to get that that painkiller which
will give you that warm fuzzy feeling
that I can't shut that off I just like I
said I just want more of that but could
you've gotten I mean if you think about
what's dangerous pots not dangerous to
an athlete like these opiates all right
direct and they're handing those out I
know it needs to be looked at
as there are alternatives and and that's
the whole thing that it's misinformation
people believe that because a doctor
prescribes it that it's okay and they
don't understand that after you know
being on it for a certain amount of time
now you're now you got this gorilla on
your back that it's hard to get off but
see you have to be now addicted to this
feeling of helping people yes your
addiction has to be that yes and you
know what it is it's I'm addicted to the
connection and I get to connect on a
whole different level today I used to be
so scared of people I'm telling you and
that's what I why I retreated to my
solution to life which was drugs and
alcohol I couldn't I couldn't do this I
couldn't go out in public I was always
just afraid dan I was completely afraid
and it's not like that today and I am
addicted to the connection of with
people talking to Todd Marinovich former
USC Raiders quarterback I mean you told
the story in the CFL where you're
getting high at halftime yes you don't
heroine at halftime
yes yeah could somebody have told you
though because sometimes if you don't
get it like if I if this Todd Marinovich
talks to Todd Marinovich who's 25 right
it's 25-year old Todd Marinovich listen
to this Todd Marinovich good question I
don't know and I can't get caught up in
is the message going to be heard I just
have to bring the message and hopefully
that something clicks with and I target
you know high school kids because that's
where I started to go astray and
somebody close to me said you know what
Todd you need to start earlier because
it might be too late yes or no no you're
right absolutely cuz when I talked to
friends we're doing it at eleven twelve
before they even get to high school you
look fuller you look healthy you did not
look good the last time you were here
yeah that's hollow
you're very I don't know it dad I don't
know if I said to the Dennis I said I
the Danny I thought you I I thought you
were using even a year ago you know I
was on my way if I was it and and like I
said I've had
physik physical sobriety but this is
completely different I'm living by
spiritual principles like I mentioned
honesty and what a way to live and it's
a way out I didn't you know what I was
under that under the grips of this
illness that is it's a it's a sad
depressed
well addiction is undefeated good boy
right daddy if the rest of your life
addiction is always there in the on-deck
circle yeah it's just there it is
undefeated at the great points these
kids are waiting I couldn't one of the
concepts that had really a hard time
with it was the surrender I have to
surrender and being an athlete
surrenders to lose you know so I had to
really re-evaluate really my life but
you talked about you know your dad kind
of got you ready for this he controlled
you and said this is who you're going to
be yeah they're going to be this thing
you're not a person you're a thing I
know it's apples and oranges but just
the controlling aspect of Lavar ball
with Lonzo ball uh-huh is there is there
anything that you see that brings back
any kind of memories like that you know
my dad was a fantastic coach but as a
parent he lacked a lot and but did your
dad want to be the star
because Lavar ball wants to be the stone
I don't think Marv was looking for the
limelight and I just know that it was
his passion - can I help an athlete
enhance his athleticism and he thought
about that for 50 years and so and he
was great at it and I think you know
what he helped me become you know the
athlete and player that I was
but there's a lot other areas to like
but but if he had developed worked on
developing you just as a person yeah how
does this thing decisions and he'll sit
and he'll tell you that he didn't if he
were to do it again it would be allowing
me to make some decisions probably made
everything everything my only decision
that my first big decision which was
which university to go to and that's a
huge one yeah and I really didn't make
that because the pressure the family to
go to SDI my dad went there furth yeah
but I thought I felt like God I'm gonna
let people down if I don't you look
great thank you no and I I looked
forward to you coming in because I it's
just like with Ryan Leaf he was in
prison
I mean he's as low as you can go and
sometimes it takes that yeah you know
get somebody to kick your teeth in and
say correct we're all looking at you you
know what it's by the grace of God I sit
here because I always believed that I
wasn't put on this planet to throw
spirals and I didn't really throw too
many spirals anyway but now I know what
it is and it's to share my story and to
you think you should be dead I do
without a doubt there's been so many
from from cartwheeling a car on the five
freeway to overdoses to you know what I
am so grateful I'm sitting right here
with you today Dan alright just embrace
it though be addicted to this I am be
addicted and the thing about my story is
if I'm not continuing on this path
you'll hear about it no I know I write I
read all about it Todd I read all about
it my friends say when we don't see you
on the other good you can learn more
about Todd and the great artwork that he
does and I hope you're continuing to do
this oh I love it it's part of my
recovery great yes continue to do it
Todd Marinovich calm we'll talk to Rich
Eisen coming up next right here on the
Dan Patrick show
[Music]
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience